All right,
here we go.
Three,
boom.
And we're live.
How are you sir?
I'm fine.
Pretty good.
Thank you for doing this.
I appreciate it.
That's fine.
My pleasure.
Who roped you into this?
Well,
I think,
I suppose James Tag Probably.
I,
uh,
I'm a big fan of your work.
I've read much of your work.
I've seen many of your interviews and
videos online.
And,
uh,
one of the things that I really wanted
to talk to you about it I find quite
interesting is consciousness and your
belief that consciousness is not simply
calculation,
but that there's something more to it
and what,
what you think this more could possibly
be from a scientific perspective,
which is unusual because a lot of people
have some theories about consciousness,
but they're usually crazy people like
myself.
Well,
I mean,
we're all conscious and so we may have
theories about it.
Yeah.
But now the ideas came by a somewhat
roundabout route.
Uh,
I,
I went to Cambridge do graduate work.
It was mathematics.
I was working on pure mathematical
subjects,
Algebra,
geometry.
But I thought,
you know,
we've got three years.
I'll spend some of the time going to
other talks that might be interesting.
So I went to three talks particularly,
which had a big influence on me.
One was a talk by Herman Bondi with uh,
um,
general relativity cosmology,
wonderful tool with very sort of
animated presentation,
the Ad.
And then there was a talk by Paul Dirac,
one of the founders of quantum mechanics
and histalk what he's completely
wonderful talk to wonderful lectures as
well,
but they're completely different style.
He was very quiet and precise in what he
said and everything.
Anyway,
in the very first lecture he was talking
about the superposition principle in
quantum mechanics.
So if you have a particle and it could
be in one spot or it could be in another
spot,
then you have all sorts of states where
it can be in both places at once.
That's sort of strange,
but you've got to get used to that idea.
And he illustrated with his speech at
piece of chalk and I think he broke it
into two illustrates.
It could be in one spot or in the other.
And my mind sort of wanders at that
point.
I don't know what I was thinking about,
but I wasn't concentrating.
And about a few minutes later he'd
finished,
his description is explanation and I had
some vague memory of something about
energy,
but I didn't understand what he said.
And I've been totally mystified by this
ever since.
So I suppose if I had heard what he
said,
he would have said something to calm me
down and I sort of accepted in one way
or another.
But as it was,
it seemed to me this was a major issue.
How on earth do you have things that
don't behave according to watch porn?
The mechanic says like cricket balls and
baseballs and things like that.
Anyway,
that's two of the talks.
The course was a course by a man called
steen who talked on mathematical logic
and he explained things like girdle's
theorem and touring machines during
machines being their mathematical notion
upon which modern computers are based or
computers basically.
And uh,
uh,
the thing about girdles there and you
see,
I'd heard,
I used to have a colleague when I was
undergraduate in first of all,
who was,
who became a scientist later on.
And we talked about,
uh,
logic and you know,
how you could make these kind of
mathematical systems,
which worked out logic.
And I'd heard about this girls there and
which seem to say that there were things
in mathematics that you just couldn't
prove.
And I didn't like that idea,
but I,
when I heard the,
when I went to this course by steen and
he explained what it really says and
what it says is,
suppose you've got a method of proving
things in mathematics.
And when I say things,
I mean things with numbers.
That one famous example is fair Mars
last year,
uh,
there's the Goldberg conjecture,
which isn't yet proved that every,
even number bigger than two is the sum
of two prime numbers.
This is sort of example of the thing.
It's just sort of mathematical things
about numbers,
which you can see what they mean.
Uh,
but it may be very difficult to see
whether it's true or untrue.
But the idea often is in mathematics
you've got a system of methods of proof.
And the key thing about these methods of
proof is that you can have a computer
check.
Whether you've done it right.
So these rules,
you know,
they could be adding in B,
it's the same as bna and things like
that.
And you,
um,
if you give you,
you say to the computer,
say,
here's a Theorem,
like Goldbar conjecture and you see
whether it can be proved and you say,
maybe I've got a proof and this follows
the steps and you give it to the
computer and it says,
Yep,
you've done it right.
It's true.
Or maybe it will say you've done it
right and it's not true.
Or it may not see anything but just go
on forever.
But these are the sorts of outcomes.
And the point about it is that if you
believe that these procedures do give
you a proof,
in other words,
that if the algorithm says,
yeah,
it's true,
then you believe that it is true because
you've understood the,
all the rules.
He looked at the first one,
so yeah,
that's okay.
You look at the second one said,
mom,
oh yeah,
I see.
Okay,
that's great.
And you go all the way down.
And as long as you convinced all those
rules work and if it says yes,
that's something you believe.
Okay,
now what girl shows as he constructs a
very specific sentence,
a statement which is a number thing
like,
like we fair most lost their arm or
something to think about numbers,
which what he shows is if you trust this
algorithm for proving mathematical
things,
then you can see by the way it's
constructed that it's true,
but you can also see by the way it's
constructed that it cannot be proved by
this procedure.
Now,
this was amazing to me because it tells
me that,
okay,
you cannot formalize your understanding
in in a scheme which you could put on a
computer.
You see this statement which skeletal
comes up with is something you can see
on the basis of the same understanding
that allows you to trust the rules that
it's true,
but that is not actually derived by the
rules.
It you see,
it's true by virtue of your belief in
the rules.
And this to me was amazing and I
thought,
Golly,
you know what's understanding?
What does it mean?
Is it something following rules?
This is an algorithm.
Well this more or less as,
it's not an algorithm because whenever
it was,
there will be something that you could
still see his true even though you don't
get it through the algorithm that you
had in the first place.
So this was a lot of subtleties about
this to people argue about endlessly.
But it was pretty convincing to me that
the shows that we don't think when we
understand something,
what's going on in our heads is not an
algorithm.
It's not following rules,
it's something else.
It's something that requires our
conscious appreciation of what we're
thinking about.
I'm thinking it's a conscious thing and
understanding is a conscious activity.
So I formed the view that conscious
activities,
whatever they are,
not just that kind of thing,
but you know,
playing music or we're falling in love
or whatever these things might be on,
not computations.
There's something else going on.
And then I thought,
because I,
you know,
I like to think of myself as a scientist
and I think that was going in our heads
is according to the laws of physics and
these laws of physics,
um,
pretty good.
They seem to work well and the outside
world.
And so I believe that the laws that work
in our heads are the same as those laws.
So I began to think about it.
Well,
what about Newton's mechanics?
you could put that on a computer.
What about Einstein's special
relativity?
You could do that.
What about Maxwell's wonderful
equations,
which tell you how less electricity and
magnetism operates and light and radio
waves and all these things.
That's all follows this beautiful set of
equations that Max will produced.
You can put that on a computer.
Okay.
Then you might have to about
approximations and the,
these depend on continuous numbers
rather than discreet things,
but I didn't think that's the answer
then I thought,
what about general relativity?
Einstein's theory of gravity with curved
space and all that.
We are familiar now with Lego,
this detector,
which is detected black hole spiraling
into each other from distant galaxy and
how do we know that those signals are
black holes,
but well,
because of calculations,
people who put this thing on an
algorithm and you know what those
signals look like.
So Einstein's general relativity.
Sure you can put that in a coop on the
computer.
What about quantum mechanics?
Well,
there's the famous equation of
Schrodinger which tells you how a
quantum state evolves.
You could put that on a computer too.
It's difficult in many ways.
There's many more parameters you have to
worry about,
but it's just this computable as these
other things.
Well,
you see,
I then remember direct lecture you see
and how it is that these things that
work in the quantum world don't seem to
work at the level of classical big
things.
And it all depends on this process of
what's called measurement in quantum
mechanics.
And the measurement process is something
that you learn how to do,
but it's not the Schrodinger equation.
It's something else.
And Schroeder himself was very intrigued
by this fact that his own equation gives
you nonsense and you the famous
Schrodinger's cat where he produces a
situation in which the cat would be dead
and alive at the same time.
He produced that in an example simply to
demonstrate that roughly speaking,
his equation gives you nonsense under
these circumstances.
So there's something else and the
something else goes beyond our current
quantum mechanics.
And it tells you what happens when the
quantum state makes a decision between,
doesn't follow the Schrodinger equation
of one thing or the other.
No,
everybody knows that who does quantum
mechanics,
but they think,
oh it's what's called making a
measurement and you're allowed to do
something different.
But that didn't make sense to me.
And so I had the view that okay,
there is a big gap and our understanding
and if there is something in the world
which isn't something you could put on a
computer,
that's where it is.
So the view,
I held that for a long time and uh,
that there,
there's something non computable,
something beyond computation involved in
our understandings of things.
So that's a view of health for ages.
I didn't do much with it.
I just held the view until,
I think there was a radio talk between
Marvin Minsky and Edward,
Fred,
Ken,
and they were explaining about what
computers can do.
And they were talking about,
okay,
you have a computer,
two computers talking to each other over
there and you walk up to the room and
the time you've walked up the room to
the computers,
they have computed.
Community communicates with each other
more thoughts than the human race ever
has done.
You see?
And I thought,
well,
I see where you're coming from,
but I don't think that's what's
happening in,
in human communication.
Human understanding is something
different from what computers do.
And consciousness is the key thing.
Consciousness is something different
from computation.
So I've held that view.
But then when I heard this talk by
Minsky and um,
and fred skin,
I thought,
well,
I had ideas of writing a book some time,
you a long time in the future when I'm
retired.
This is some while back I said,
and I thought,
well,
maybe this gives you the focus.
And so I wrote this book called the
emperor's new mind,
which was supposed to be saying,
well,
you know,
we,
uh,
everybody seems to be thinking one
thing,
but yeah,
the little kid notices that the emperor
doesn't have any clothes.
So it was the,
uh,
that theme of that story,
which was the basis of the book.
So I say,
okay,
maybe a lots of people think that,
well,
we're doing this computing,
but if you stand back and you say,
well,
no,
there's something else going on.
So that was the basis of my thoughts
about consciousness.
But I wrote this book thinking that by
the time I got to the end of the book,
you see,
it was,
it was a lot,
a lot,
mostly about physics and mathematics and
things like that.
But I was really aiming for this thing
about what's going on and conscious
thinking.
And I thought,
well,
I'll learn a bit about neurophysiology
and so on.
And by the time I get to the end of the
book,
uh,
know pretty well what it could be.
I didn't got to the end of the book and
I just sort of tapered off rather than
with something a little bit
unbelievable.
And that was the end.
Now you see,
I hope that this book would stimulate
young people to get interested in
science and that sort of thing,
that mathematics.
And that was fine.
And when the book was published,
I didn't get letters from young kids.
I got letters from old retired people
who,
the ones who'd had the time to read my
book.
Okay,
well that was a little disappointing,
but okay,
I'm glad the old retired people like my
book.
But the other thing was I got a letter
from Stuart Hameroff and this letter
said more or less,
I think you don't appreciate that
there's something else going on.
Not Neurons.
I mean the neurons,
I could see you couldn't isolate the
quantum effects and that the,
you get the what's called an
environmental decoherence would happen
and you get no way of keeping the
quantum state to the level that you need
in this picture.
So I really,
I didn't have it,
but Stuart Hameroff pointed out to me
these little things called microtubules
and he'd built up a theory that
microtubules are absolutely fundamental.
The consciousness.
He had his own reasons for believing
that I had never heard of them at that
time,
but then I checked up,
you know,
I get lots of letters from people who
maybe don't make sense sometimes the
letters and this one I thought,
well this is another one.
Then I realized these microtubules are
there and they looked like just the kind
of thing that could well be supporting
the kind of level of quantum mechanics
up to a level where you could expect the
the quantum state to sort of collapse.
That's the terminology.
People using quantum mechanic micro
tubules are inside brain neurons.
They are indeed.
And this is a recent discovery for them.
No,
they're actually in lots of cells.
You see,
people often complain,
oh,
they're in your liver too,
not just your brain.
So why isn't your liver conscious and
all that.
But it has to do with the organization
of them and the nature of them,
the particular kind of microtubules,
how they're,
how they're arranged,
which is different in the brain.
How does it vary in the brain compared
to other cells?
I think one big difference,
although not Stewart emphasizes,
there's so much,
there are two kinds of microtubules.
They're the ones who have a lattice and
the bead lattice and the a lattice ones
are,
they're very symmetrical ones.
There are tubes and they look the same
all the way around.
They've got a very beautiful arrangement
of these proteins called Tubulin and
they make a very nice arrangement,
which is connected with fibonacci
numbers and things like that.
So they look a bit like for cones,
but there were powerful.
They're not,
they don't,
um,
take her off.
But um,
the thing is in the brain,
I think most of microtubules are
probably what I be lattice ones.
And they're don't have so much symmetry.
They've got like a sort of seemed on the
one side and they're very important in
transporting some substances around
cells and so on.
And Microsoft was all sorts of things.
They don't just do what what stuart and
I think they may be doing in the brain.
So the idea is that in the brain they're
organized differently and probably the
ones that are important have a lattice
ones,
which is a very symmetrical ones.
And for a long time people couldn't see
the difference and um,
cause they look very similar.
Um,
and they may well be the ones that have
to be in pyramidal cells as a particular
kind of cell.
So you know,
one of the things that interested in me
a lot is how it is that not all parts of
the brain are the same in this respect
is that you've got the cerebrum,
this is the part at the top and divided
down the middle on that.
When you see brains,
that's what you normally see with the
convolutions in,
in the,
in it,
but right underneath and at the back
there's a thing called the cerebellum,
which more it looks more like a,
like a ball of wool or something.
And the Cerebellum,
and it may still be argument about this,
but it seems to be that it's completely
unconscious and it has comparable number
of neurons,
far more connections between neurons and
the cerebrum.
And it's what takes control.
And maybe when you're driving your car
and you're thinking about something else
and you,
you don't,
you're not thinking what you're doing
because it's unconscious.
And the unconscious control,
you know,
a pianist who was very expert and moves
the fingers around and plays a note with
a little finger,
that pns doesn't think,
well,
I've got to move that muscle this way
and this bone that way and so on.
And it's,
it's all controlled unconsciously.
And a lot of this unconscious control is
done somewhere else in the cerebellum
when you,
when you get really skilled.
So,
uh,
it seemed to me,
okay,
you've got different kinds of structures
different,
and it could well be that these
pyramidal cells,
which have a particular organization of
microtubules,
are the ones that were,
that consciousness is really coming,
coming to light.
Mainly,
I don't know.
There's a lot which is,
which is not known about this
controversial and all sorts of things,
but the cerebellum seems to be different
and organized differently.
So it's not just how many neurons,
how many connections are there because
there are more in the cerebellum,
so it's not that same else.
Do they know this from observing the
brain through Fmr dry or something like
that during particular activities?
Like Ah,
I don't know.
I would imagine he partly just examining
it went from dead people and looking at
brains and trying to estimate how many
neurons their own it.
Right.
But how would they know what,
which partial,
which is consciousness.
It's pretty mellow.
I don't know that they do know that when
I guess,
but the,
the cerebellum,
there is a bit of an argument about that
I think whether it's completely
unconscious or not,
but it seems that actions that,
that are carried out by the cerebellum.
You don't,
you're not aware of what you're doing.
But I mean it's,
you know,
if he had the tennis player who has to
think very carefully about whether with
tilt the ball now that the control of
what you're doing,
so the overall control,
it's probably done with the cerebrum,
but the cerebellum is controlling the
detailed motions,
how the fingers move and all that kind
of thing.
And then you'd make sure that if you
play your thinks going to hit the ball
down down the line there and then the,
the rest is done under the control of an
unconscious procedure.
I mean,
I may be simplifying,
but you're saying,
so you're saying that there's,
we don't totally understand,
but we know that there's different parts
of the brain that are responsible for
different activities and some activities
don't seem to be conscious.
Yes.
I mean,
I think it's probably the case.
No,
I'm,
I'm maybe,
I don't know.
I shouldn't make a statement and I don't
really know,
but certainly there are lots of
different parts of the cerebrum which
maybe,
which maybe not conscious too,
so I'm not saying that the whole thing
is capable of being conscious.
It's,
they seem to be differences in different
parts,
but are you convinced that microtubules
are responsible for consciousness or
it's a primary theory?
I think they're the one of the best
candidates.
I you see,
I don't think it's only microtia.
I Dunno.
I'm not sure what Stuart Hameroff view
on this is.
He certainly thinks the micro g was
exceedingly important in consciousness
and I think he's right.
That's the feeling I get and he's done a
lot of work on trying to find a what?
Anesthetic gases.
It's an important,
one of the important ways you can tell
things about conscious and most of it
you can't,
it's just hearsay.
What does it vary?
It is,
but one of the important ways you can
tell something about consciousness is
what turns it off in a reversible way.
In Stuart's job is,
do you know he's an anesthesiologist?
He puts people to sleep well,
I think he would complain if I say
putting it to sleep because under
anesthetic is actually different for
sleep,
but you make them unconscious in a
reversible way.
You want to make sure you think you can
wake them up again.
And a,
it's obviously a very skills thing,
but I guess a lot of his colleagues
might be a skilled at doing it,
but don't.
They asked the questions about what
they're actually doing from the point of
view of the biology and the physics and
so on.
So it still,
it was really interested in that
question.
Partly I think the thing is like,
oh my tosas cell division and he was
very struck by the way that the
chromosomes or lion lion up and that
there's these microtubules which pulling
them and they're really a big part in,
in,
in the structure of cells and how they,
how they behave and so on.
But why they are consciousness.
Well,
I guess it was an experience with,
with um,
putting people under anesthetics and the
fact that the gases which put you to
sleep,
and there again,
I shouldn't say to sleep,
but put you on the anesthetic.
I'm very unconnected chemically.
They're different kinds of things be yet
they still seem to have the same effect
and to understand what it is that they
affect is,
you know,
there's a lot of his interest is to do
with that.
So just by putting someone unconscious
and registering what parts of the brain
are no longer active,
this is what they're using to sort of
reverse engineered by turning those
parts on.
That's what enables consciousness is
this,
well,
I think it's probably a simplification
of what's going on,
but that's,
that's a good,
uh,
first first step.
Yes.
Consciousness becomes as a subject,
it's very,
it's,
it's very susceptible to woo.
Right.
Indeed.
I guess it's one of those weird ones
where people want to start talking about
souls and universal consciousness and
they start,
it gets,
yeah,
it's a murky area and there's no clear
borderline with cc student runs these
consciousness conferences and he's very
broad minded.
He has people all sorts of different
views like the ones you mentioned,
and it's not necessarily his view,
but he likes to get a broad perspective
on what's going on.
I,
I'm a bit more narrow minded than he is
on these matters.
Yeah,
I am too.
I'm very skeptical because I just,
I understand the inclination that people
have to lean towards the woo then it's
very fun.
Yes.
It's for
whatever reason people are inclined to
lean towards,
do you ever see,
you saw that movie,
I don't know if you saw a,
what the bleep do we know?
Oh yes,
I did not go.
That kind of stuff.
That was a little worrying to me that
yes,
indeed.
Now that did worry me.
Yeah.
Well,
it's uh,
it's just,
you know,
it was written,
the movie was made by a cult leader and
now it gets a little squirrelly.
Right.
You're absolutely right.
And I,
I,
as I say,
I was distinctly,
I'm sure you were a lot of people that I
know there were like yourself,
we're worried,
but it's,
this is something that everyone
contemplates.
Like what makes you conscious?
What is the soul?
Is it a real thing?
What is,
what is your consciousness?
Is it simply just your own biology
trying to calculate your environment and
looking out for his best interests and
trying to procreate and move forward
with the,
the genes that had has,
or is it something almost mystical or
far more complicated?
Maybe even instead of the word mystical
might be tainted maybe something far
more complex than we're currently able
to understand?
I think to some extent I would agree to
it because it's any different,
I need to have some internal perception
of the external world and yeah,
have to think abstractly and all these
things,
it's totally different from a way a
baseball runs through the air.
And what,
what makes it spin and different than
every other conscious animal?
I'm not so sure about that.
No,
I think the difference isn't that big.
I mean,
okay,
we,
you know,
we use language to a degree.
I mean,
some animals use language to some kind
of degree.
There's a huge difference in degree.
I agree with that.
But whether it's a difference in kind,
I'm not a total sure.
Um,
you know,
you watch these nature movies and I
remember seeing one about elephants and
this was about how the elephants were.
They always,
uh,
they're always led by a female elephant
that's not relevant to the story.
But they were trying to go from a to B,
I don't know,
maybe what it was.
And they thought that was a whole herd
of them then would be doing that.
But then at a certain point they made a
detour and they went off to a place
where the leader of the elephant herd,
her sister had died and that the bones,
the tusks I suppose with their bones
anyway with that and the elephants
picked him up,
handed them around and and seem to
caress them and move them around and
then they went back and joined to the
the route that they want.
Now what does that tell us?
There's something going on which is not
just some machine behaving like a robot.
There's some,
some feelings that that we can
appreciate.
I mean another one I remember was one
with these,
a punt I African hunting dogs and the
dogs.
You see there's a route where some
antelopes we tend to go and had to go
across the river and when they got to
the point where the crossfit and that
slow
down and,
and make their way to get across.
Now these hunting dogs,
you could see them,
I think it was taken from the air and
they would go along towards this place
where the river was and then they would
break into two.
So half of them would go one way towards
the,
and they would hide just where the river
starts and the other half would go and
chase the antelopes.
They'd gone bark and make an awful noise
chasing them right there.
And then the other ones were pants on
them.
I mean there's something there which is,
you know,
there'd been working it out between
themselves.
How's it doing?
Commute communication of some kind.
Yes.
And I think there is,
what will you call understanding.
Okay.
It's a more primitive level and then
human understanding.
But nevertheless there was something,
there's no sort of clean dividing line
in my view it's,
it's,
it's pretty continuous.
Yeah.
And this exists in wolves as well,
so very,
very similar behavior.
And they do seem to have not just verbal
but nonverbal communication.
They seem to have some understanding of
what the task is and what their roles
are in the task.
And even though there's not as many
variables maybe as human life there,
there definitely seems to be a conscious
awareness of,
first of all,
their,
their position in the hierarchy of the
tribe of the pack,
but also their,
what their objective is.
This,
this is not a selfish objective.
It's a group objective and they operate
as a group and they do move like those
African dogs you were talking about.
Yeah.
No,
it's fascinating.
I love that.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of indication that
we're certainly chimps and elephants and
things in dolphins.
You,
we know about them,
but I imagine it goes quite far down,
I should think.
How much have you studied a Octopi?
They're fascinating.
Yeah.
Yes.
No,
I haven't.
There's a new book about them,
which I haven't gotten the chance to
read yet.
I wanted to read it.
I think they're,
they're highly intelligent.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
I've only different really paying
attention to them for a few years.
I have a,
a good friend.
My Friend Remy Warren was doing a
television show,
um,
called Apex Predator.
We studied the way different animals
hunted and he started studying the way
octopus and um,
uh,
cuddle fish and all these different,
yeah,
different,
uh,
Octopi and what the way they could adapt
to their environment by changing their
actual,
they'll,
they'll not just to look,
but the texture of their skin
instantaneously and how this is not
really understood how the,
not only how they do it,
but how they know what they're,
what's below them,
what they're copying.
Yes.
That they somehow or another can figure
out how to blend in almost perfectly
with their environment.
It's amazing isn't it?
They also can open jars and they can
climb out of tanks.
There was one guy had a,
he had a camera on his tank because he
had two tanks and one of them had very
expensive tropical fish and the other
one had his octopus and he was
trying to figure out what was happening
to his expensive tropical fish.
We put a camera on it and the octopus
was climbing out of the tank,
walking across the ground,
climbing into the other tank,
killing one of the fish,
eating it,
and then going back into his tank.
Yes.
Yeah,
that's heavy.
Well,
there's one I saw,
but I think I heard the description or I
read it.
I think I read it about some experiments
on testing the intelligence of octopuses
or,
and they had a,
a little thing they had to pull the
chain and then open a door and get food
out.
And this octopus was thinking then I'm
getting fed up with this thing and so
yank the chain.
It came right off and then it rose to
the top and started to squirting all the
people in their white coats.
So I know that was pretty good.
You know,
there's something else going on that
Justin is something going on.
Absolutely.
Now when you,
if you weren't pressed for tea to figure
this out in some sort of a,
a paper that you had to display in front
of scientists.
If you were,
you were like,
you're trying to figure out like what do
you think it is?
Like what,
what do you think consciousness is where
you say,
I mean to,
it's going too far to think,
you know,
I know that the answer,
is there anything of course.
I just think that this issue of having
some kind of quantum state,
which preserves itself up to a certain
level and the microtubules at least
suggested something where you could
isolate them from the outside and the
symmetry of these things is important.
And there are other structures.
I suspect it's not just microtubules.
I suspect there are these um,
classrooms,
these are molecules which inhabit the
synapses.
And um,
and the thing about these ones is that
they're incredibly symmetrical.
They're like a soccer ball.
You know there you have these pentagons
and excellence and each vertex you've
got a protein,
it's called a [inaudible] and they
joined themselves along the edges of
the,
of the pattern of the soccer mom.
Okay.
But it's just the,
it's just a substance.
I mean it's made of these proteins and
what are they doing hanging around in
the synopsis,
I dunno,
but they,
the symmetry has a key role.
There's a thing called the young teller
effect in quantum mechanics,
which tells you that when you have a
highly symmetrical structure like that,
then there can be a big gap between the
lowest energy level and the next one.
And there can be information in this
lowest energy level,
which can be shielded from the higher
energy levels.
So this is a sort of the suggestion that
some kind of quantum phenomenon is going
on in the serious way.
And there's a lot to understand there.
I mean synopsis themselves,
that kind of strange things.
You might think if you were going to
build a brain,
why don't you just sold a little wires
together,
the connections,
you see what you're doing.
Having this thing with all the chemist
chemicals transferring this information
from one side,
I don't know,
but it's something very needed for by
the system and it's all tied up with
these classrooms there and and
Cytoskeleton structures,
which microtubials I one of the main
constituents.
So you see,
I don't know that there's a lot to
learn,
I'm sure.
So it seems like there's a,
a bunch of different factors.
There's the biological understanding of
the brain itself.
Yeah.
And then there's the understanding of
the actual nature of cells and of
reality itself that this is being more
illuminated by science with every new
discovery.
You know,
we're getting a better understanding,
deeper and deeper as to the very nature
of matter and of of the,
of these structures themselves.
I think it is getting deep into the end
of the way the physical world operates
and things we don't understand about it
just yet.
Yes.
I mean the biology is one side of it and
not,
you know,
coming as an outsider,
I get struck by seth and things.
I'm going to be quite familiar with the
fact that the right signs of the
cerebrum controllers,
the left hand and the left hand,
the right hand,
but then you look at this and it's not
just that.
What about the soles of your feet right
at the top.
What about your eyes?
They signals right at the back you can
think this is the most ridiculous
construction you you're going to do the
worst possible place.
Yes.
There must be a reason and the
cerebellum is different cause cerebellum
is the left side controls the left side
and the right side.
The right side.
Did this something going on which
involves these signals getting,
having to cross each other or whatever
it is.
I Dunno.
Well we'd like to think that there's a
reason but then we look at other
biological life forms and they look kind
of preposterous.
Like a platypus.
For instance.
You look at that and go,
what is that?
It was out of the experiment.
Is that a prototype that just ran wild
in Islam as well?
I get it.
You got to think of it in terms of
natural select shoreham source.
Yeah.
I guess the circumstances though,
I don't know.
In Australia,
wherever you find it must be specific.
I guess the a lot of that was because
they were isolated from,
from the rest of the,
so you get sort of strange animals in
Australia and in New Zealand where a lot
of isolation from,
from the rest of the evolution.
So they did their own thing there.
Yeah.
Marsupials which is intriguing,
isn't it?
Well the,
the,
the phrase quantum is another one that's
fraught with woo indeed.
Right.
And some people like Deepak Chopra and
the like,
they love to use that word because as
soon as you use that word you could kind
of get away with almost anything
afterwards.
Yes.
I have to say I have quantum mechanics
is a strange thing and it's,
I saw the blame me for certain things I
don't want,
I don't want to be unfair here.
I'm not saying no as I blame it.
It gives some people have the
impression,
okay,
the fact your theory doesn't make any
sense.
That's nothing against it.
You say crazy things.
Quantum mechanics is crazy.
So we wanted to except some other crazy
theory.
Of course quantum mechanics has the
virtue of that.
It does agree with an awful lot of
experiments.
It gives you a huge insight since the
things that that one didn't have before.
So just the fact that it's crazy isn't,
isn't enough to,
to make,
to make it something you should study
seriously.
Well,
um,
well it's very,
very difficult to understand even for
people who study it.
Yes,
indeed.
So for someone like myself,
I'm trying to pay attention to this
without devoting my entire life to it.
And it gets,
it's becomes a big problem because
there's,
yeah.
Yeah.
Are there too,
I in one of my books had tried to
explain there are actually two mysteries
in quantum mechanics and they get
muddled.
One of them is the whole subject is
pretty crazy.
Yes.
But it's coherent and it makes sense.
And if you study it properly and you
say,
okay,
that,
that makes sense.
And this includes things like non local
effects where you can have two things
now they know eating thousands of
kilometers apart and you can see these
quantum entanglement effects.
Yes,
there they are still in some sense
connected with each other even though
they're that far apart,
which is pretty amazing.
That's baffling.
But that's part of the comprehensive or
part of quantities.
It's muddied up because there's the
other part which has to do with this
collapse of the wave function and
standard quantum mechanics really
doesn't make sense,
but people get them muddled in my year
you think because this doesn't make
sense and that's,
well it's all a bit crazy and so
anything crazy is,
is is up for grabs,
but it seems to me that quantum
mechanics,
the things which are crazy and they do
hang together and the theory works and
you understand that that's fine,
but the things which involve the
collapse of the wave function,
that's not fine because we don't have
the right theory.
That's why it doesn't make logical sense
because it's not the right theory yet.
That's my view.
I mean,
I'm a minority and saying this,
most people who study the foundations of
quantum mechanics,
they,
well,
we haven't got the right interpretation
right yet.
We have to think when it means and so
on.
They don't think,
well,
hmm,
maybe it's not quite right.
Maybe there's something when this
affects get big enough,
something else comes in and we need a
new insights and new theory.
So that's what I think
now in something like super position
where something can be both still and in
motion at the same time.
As soon as you say that.
Yeah,
to the common person like myself,
my brain glazes over and uh,
my eyebrows raised up and I go,
okay,
what does,
and then you're talking about
entanglement things hundreds of
thousands of kilometers apart that are
somehow or another interacting with each
other in a way that we don't totally
understand.
Or we don't have a theory that
absolutely explains in a concrete way
when it does,
as long as you don't get to the
measurement,
the measurement entanglement part is
pretty well understood.
But the measurement,
the measurement part is not be seen as
the puzzles
about the entanglement is when you come
to the measurement,
you make a measurement over here and the
measurement over there and they can be,
well now a thousand kilometers apart.
The record was only 143 or something.
It's a little while ago.
Wow.
That's,
it's a,
it's a long time,
a long distance,
but there's hardly any movement of
material.
So the thing that you see in the scheme
I have,
which involves the collapse of the wave
function involves certain amount of
displacement and mass.
Now,
if it's just photons that's light and
these experiments tend to be just light,
then there's no mass displacement in the
state.
And so sure what quantum mechanics says
is fine by me.
Okay.
It's hard to get your mind around and I
certainly agree with that,
but it's logical.
It's not logical comes apart.
But when you worry about the measurement
issue and the collapse of the wave
function and portal,
Schrodinger was very upset by this quite
right.
Yes.
Now when you discuss consciousness and
the mystery of consciousness and then
you take into account some of these
characteristics that are being displayed
in the quantum world,
do you think that perhaps some of them
are interchangeable or,
or similar to consciousness itself,
that there is some sort of a connection
that human beings share and some,
some strange,
unique and miss or not,
not understood way yet?
I think one of the
careful about these things and sometimes
do well,
even Niels Bohr who is one of the
founders of these ideas,
um,
and so,
uh,
he tried to make a philosophy out of
quantum mechanics and what do you call
it?
So complimentarity and so I think that's
going a bit far.
I don't really see cause there's no
evidence for it.
I don't think so.
I think it's a bit misleading that one,
you can see analogies between things,
but I don't see myself that that should
be taken much further than that.
But I,
you know,
maybe there's more there,
but you're open to the possibility
should new information.
Yeah.
I mean,
if it comes to things like,
you know,
when people talk about it entanglements
and things quantum states can spread to
long distances,
does that mean that human beings minds
can stretch to long distances and so on.
So the people will raise questions like
that?
I don't think so.
Myself.
I think that's,
that's pretty farfetched.
But you,
you know,
you might worry.
Well it could it be that there some
quantum state which is shared between
different individuals.
It's hard to see.
That could be,
unless they were,
well I meant if they're identical twins,
I suppose they were once in one cell at
one time,
but you'd have to preserve that
information all the way through.
And I just don't see how that can
happen.
So I'm not a fan of trying to use
quantum ideas
sort of directly and say human behavior
or something.
I think the,
those analogies are pretty far fetched,
partly because the sorts of mathematics
you use in quantum mechanics,
there's very specific to quantum
mechanics and doesn't really apply to
macroscopic behaviors.
So,
as I can see,
is this
thing that is,
uh,
that your ax asked about most often?
You mean in my research all together or
just amongst the common people?
Like myself,
it's only one of them.
But you see,
it's slightly misleading when you're
thinking about what my interests are
because I had this,
as I say,
the,
I explained more or less the history of
ideas there and I did write a book or at
least another one after that too.
In fact,
I guess I've written three books about
that time.
That one was taken down lectures and so
on.
Um,
but it's not what I do mainly,
right.
Main research is,
is,
is um,
cosmology.
Uh,
well thing is this area called twists
the theory but necessarily go into that.
But it's meant to be foundational.
Quantum is a foundational physics,
not necessarily,
but general relativity.
I mean the,
I guess the work I did originally with
people paid attention to is in,
in general relativity and black holes.
What a black hole is,
why we have the idea that they're there
at all,
that sort of thing.
I worked on that one point.
Cosmology as a whole is one of the most
terrifying concepts to me because I
just,
when I start thinking about the size and
scale of everything,
I get to a certain point and my brain
just shuts off.
There's not enough juice.
Well,
it's pretty huge.
One is has to think on a pretty huge
scale,
but it's like so many things you,
it looks sort of mind boggling at first
and then when you get used to the idea,
you can sort of play around with the
ideas and maybe forget how much bottling
it should be.
I was watching a documentary around
supermassive black holes and they were
discussing how the size of this was,
I don't know if this is still a current
theory.
This documentary was a few years old,
but they were saying that the,
there's a supermassive black hole inside
of every galaxy that's one half of 1% of
the mass of the entire galaxy.
And that they,
there's the,
one of the theories was that inside the
supermassive black holes could be an
entirely different universe with
hundreds of billions of galaxies each
with their own black holes.
And then it's
infinite.
Well,
you see,
I have a fairly,
an idea which I think the mainstream
does still regarded as a bit crazy,
but not like that.
I don't think you're going to have much
fun inside a black hole.
Nobody's in there.
Uh,
not,
not much.
Well,
you could have a really big black hole
and there's a lot of time in there who
really big one.
If you,
if you were in a space ship,
you could,
you could have a few parties before you
can get hour.
Yes.
But I'm not sure
I recommend it.
Um,
no.
Uh,
yeah,
I'm in black holes are remarkable
enough.
But I mean the thing I did,
which was in 1964 and the publish under
65 which to show that black hose,
well I'm using a terminal knowledge that
wasn't around at that time that the
black holes collide.
It was co gravitational collapse.
You see the,
this,
the history went back to originally I
guess Chandra Sekhar Indian scientist
when he was not quite 20,
I think,
I can't remember.
He's 19 or 20.
And he was going to England to study
physics,
astronomy and so on.
And he worked on this problem about what
holes white doffs apart.
These are the,
is very massive stars,
the companion of serious,
serious as a white dwarf.
And he was doing calculations to find
out whether they,
uh,
what the interior has a very
particularly as struck structure of
matter.
And he came to the conclusions if they
had a bigger mass than a certain amount,
which is about a bit less than one and a
half times the sun's mass,
they wouldn't build a home selves apart.
And so they would collapse and he didn't
speculate on what had happened.
He just,
one is less there.
Some very modest comment he made is one,
we are left speculating on possibilities
or something.
But then that was in the 1930s,
I guess round about 1930 and much later,
just before the war.
Um,
cinema one 90 13 at west,
they're a bit later,
I guess 1939,
there was a paper by oppenheimer of
atomic bomb fame and Schneider,
which is a student of his Hartland
Snyder.
And they produced a model which was,
uh,
a solution of the Einstein Equations,
which describes a cloud of dust which
collapses and becomes what we now call
the black hole there.
This was the first clear picture of
collapsed to a black hole.
Now in their picture,
they made two huge assumptions,
but one of them is does the material,
that means it didn't have any pressure.
And so you could imagine when it gets
close to itself,
it might would push away if it had
pressure on it in any way.
But this was just dust.
That was one thing,
but more important that the model was
exactly symmetrical.
So it was just very clear,
symmetrical all matter,
falling in the dust particles would be
focused right into the central point.
And so it's not so hard to believe that
you get a singularity where the density
goes infinite,
the curvatures go infinite and your
equations go crazy.
So at that point,
when the dust reaches the middle point,
okay,
it's not so surprising because it's a
very contrived situation.
So I think a lot of people thought,
well,
perhaps we shouldn't take it seriously.
They,
I think they weren't sure.
But then there was a paper by two
Russians caulk flattened lifshitz and
the Kolodny cough.
And they seem to have proved that you
didn't get singularities and the general
case that somehow it was swirl around
and switch out again.
You see?
So that was a possibility.
And then there was this discovery,
I think in 1962 when Martin Schmidt to
Dutch astronomer.
Okay.
Dutch American,
I think where he was living there at the
time,
I don't remember,
but he observed,
became what we call the,
the first quasar.
So this was an object of which was
irradiating an awful amount of energy,
far more than an entire galaxy.
But it seemed to be a very small thing.
It couldn't be much bigger than the size
of the solar system if even that big,
because it variations in brightness
indicated that the,
it's the speed of light could size of it
had to be comparable with the same speed
at which the variations in,
in,
um,
in Brighton this came about.
So it seemed to be an object that was
enormously energetic,
producing more energy than a whole
galaxy and varying with such a degree
that it must be fairly small.
And this raised the question of whether
it was small enough to be what we now
call a black hole.
In other words,
it's,
um,
there's a thing called the short,
short radius.
Schwab shocked was the man who first
discovered the solutions of Einstein's
equations,
which described this spherical body,
but he didn't extrapolate it inwards to
what's called this horizon.
We call it horizon now.
It used to be called the Schwartz at
singularity and people began to realize
that it wasn't really a singularity.
It's my something you could imagine
falling through.
I guess it was in the Metro who first
made clear that clear,
but not many people paid attention.
But that was the idea of a black hole.
And it looked then is that these quasars
could be having some back hole in the
middle of them.
And I remember John Wheeler who's at
Princeton,
then very distinguished scientist and he
got where you worried about these things
and he talked to me and he were right
about it.
And do we believe,
is there a singularity in the middle of
the,
we believe Lifshitz and Claton and
coffee,
they sort of swirl around and bounce
that.
What are we supposed to think?
So I started thinking about this problem
and since that time,
well you see either people,
when he wants to solve the Einstein
equations,
either you make a lot of assumptions and
it's a symmetrical like,
like the open home is slotted model.
You assume it's got very special
properties and then you can maybe solve
the equations.
But only very,
very special cases and the computers
weren't powerful enough to tell you very
much about what happened.
So I started thinking about this problem
and realizing that I'd have to think
about it in a different way.
And so I used ideas,
involve ideas from topology and things
like that to show that there had to be a
singularity in the middle,
provided that the collapse had reached a
certain point of no return,
I guess to get some idea of,
I dunno,
it's just not too misleading.
There's a mathematical theorem called
the hairy dog theorem.
Hairy dog pheromones.
Yes.
I mean that's just a jocular
terminology,
right?
But you think of,
uh,
something which is topologically a
sphere,
that means you see it,
you imagine a dog shape,
but you could sort of move it around
with a piece of plasticine until it
looked like a sphere.
It doesn't have holes in it.
Okay.
Forget about his digestive system.
You see,
you're thinking about the surface
outside and then you're out.
The problem is you're trying to comb the
hair on the dog all the way around and
the theorem says there's got to be
somewhere where the hair,
it doesn't lie flat and you try it on
the sphere.
There's got to be a point where with the
hair makes a kind of singular point.
So it's a bit like that.
You have no idea where the singularity
is,
but you know from general,
top logical reasons that there's got to
be one somewhere.
And that was the sort of argument that I
produced.
And uh,
I guess a lot of people had little bit
be trouble because they never seen this
kind of arguing and a lot of people
picked up on it and particular Stephen
Hawking and uh,
it became for a while,
uh,
many people working on it,
I guess it's not so popular now because
probably would run out of serums.
The idea of a singularity or is when you
see something like a,
a quasar or the,
the the center of a galaxy and we were
talking a lot of black hole.
When you say a singularity,
what?
What exactly are you do you mean by
that?
Well the normal expectation is that you
have a place like in the middle of the
Oppenheimer,
that dust cloud,
that a point there where the density
becomes infinite and so the curvature of
space time becomes infinite.
So you have a place where the equations
and run away and they go to infinity and
you say well something's gone wrong.
But maybe initially it was in these very
symmetrical cases but but you could show
by these indirect arguments that
somewhere some of these got to go wrong.
You can't continue the equations of
Einstein and they got stuck right to the
place where they go infinite or what in
detail happens.
The theorems don't tell you,
they just say that something goes wrong
and that's what we call the singularity
and if a black hole is larger or
smaller,
the singularity remains constant.
It remains in in there.
It's remains in there but it's not
measurable in terms of its actual size
or whether you can measure size very
well cause its size.
That's an intriguing question.
You might say the size is going to zero.
Right,
but it could be quite complicated in
irregular.
Not like the original opera.
I miss every one of my soldiers.
Even then the point is the wrong point
of view but let's not go into that.
Now there is something about the
structure of these things.
You can say they're not all the same.
No the singularities and all of sudden,
but the black holes are not all the
same.
They're not all the same but they this,
one of the strange things about black
holes is that if you let them settle
down,
they're not all the same to begin with
but are not many different things they
can settled into.
They can have rotation,
they can have a certain mass and the
mass translates into the size of the
diameter of the hole and you've also got
a rotation so they can rotate and these
are short sweatshirt found.
The non rotating ones and it was roy and
Australia and who first produced a
solution for a rotating black hole
rotating.
Yes,
a rotating one.
But then you see the remarkable thing is
that's what they settled down too.
So there are good theorem this which
tell you that the general black hole to
be very complicated,
fairly rapidly will settle down and
become one of these care solutions.
The rotating black hole.
I remember when I first saw that
documentary and I saw the,
when they were discussing the,
the shape of these galaxies and that the
center of it had this supermassive black
hole that was slowly devouring the
galaxy.
It is an unbelievably beautiful yet
simultaneously terrifying idea is that
there's this yes,
infinite power in the center of infinite
mass that's absorbing slowly but surely
everything around it.
But it's not an infinite mass.
The mass is quite well defined and
there's not infinite.
But yeah,
I always a good question.
I mean if you wait forever,
how much of the mass actually gets
swallowed by the black hole?
You see,
I think the,
the pictures to think not just the one
galaxy but the cluster.
You see our galaxy has this 4 million
solar mass black hole and we are on a
collision course with the Andromeda
Galaxy.
And I don't know how long,
but many book some time in the future.
Yes.
The black holes,
we'll probably spile into each other and
there'll be one big one.
So it's definable mass,
but in infinite density and that this
point,
which were,
they were speculating that this could
possibly in the center of the
supermassive black holes,
if you could go through that,
there would be another universe.
Well,
you see that's speculation.
So nice romantic thought.
Ooh,
is it more woo,
I'm afraid.
So it's also good though.
Yes,
I know what it's a shame for science
fiction because it makes a nice thing
that we try to make things more
complicated than they are because
they're so complicated as it is dark
matter for instance,
it,
it boggles the mind that we don't really
totally understand what 90 plus percent.
Well,
that's a good question.
And what does that stuff,
well,
you want me to tell you my theory?
Yes,
please.
Well,
you see,
it's part of a story,
which I don't know,
about 15 years ago,
I must've years of passing back on,
remember how long ago now?
So I had this idea,
you see,
the universe as a whole is expanding
now,
um,
early in the this century.
Don't ask me dates again.
Um,
some people by observing Supernova
supernovas saw exposing sauce very,
very far away.
They found out that the university is
actually accelerating in its expansion.
And some people found this very
mysterious.
On the other hand,
it's in all the cosmology books because
there is that expectation.
You see,
in 1915,
Einstein produced his general theory.
In 1917 he introduced what's called the
cosmological constant.
So you think of a,
it was called lambda,
you think of a,
a v shape turned upside down,
which is a member.
And he introduced this term for the
wrong reason because at that time people
weren't,
there was some indication in the
universe was expanding but not very
clear.
An Einstein,
uh,
I guess maybe didn't know,
I didn't believe it.
And this,
it,
the couples observations hadn't yet come
to make a convincing case of the
expansion.
So I saw,
I thought,
well,
maybe the universe is static.
It's kind of philosophically nice to
think that it's sitting there all the
time.
And he couldn't make it do that.
Uh,
so he had to introduce this term called
the cosmological constant and he did
that and then not while very much longer
after this Hobo showed the universe does
seem to be expanding and Einstein
regarded this lamb the term as his
biggest blunder,
which is an irony because it turns out
that this term is probably the
explanation for the expansion of the
universe that we now see.
So it's what people call dark energy.
I don't like the term very much cause
it's neither dark,
no proper energy in any clear sense.
But still that was not worry about that.
It's a,
it's an odd term.
Yes,
I think so.
It's a little confusing cause it's dark
matter as well,
which is quite different.
You know,
I must be confused with the dark energy
as it's called of the cosmological
constant,
which as far as we can tell,
it is completely consistent with the
observations.
It's a positive number,
very small,
but it seems to be producing this
expansion.
And I'm quite happy with that viewpoint
because it leads to a picture,
which I've been trying to plug for
awhile now,
maybe up to 15 years.
I can't remember.
Um,
the idea,
I said it's hard to explain,
but let me try.
It came about because I was worrying
about the remote future and I was
thinking,
oh,
okay.
When these black holes around,
they swallowed up all the stars and
they're just sitting around.
And what's the most next exciting thing
happening?
Well,
the hawking evaporation,
they're going to radiate away.
Stephen Hawking showed that black holes
had this temperature extremely cold.
I mean the,
these enormous ones are absurdly cold,
much colder than anything made on the
earth.
And uh,
but when the universe expands and
expands and expands,
it gets colder than the black holes.
And so those black holes become the
hottest,
hottest things around.
And so they radiate away very,
very slowly.
This hawking radiation and that carries
energy.
And so they shrink and the shrink and
the shrink.
And finally they disappear with a pop.
I said pop is probably a pretty big
explosion,
but,
but I'm not that big from a cosmological
astrophysical scale.
So the disappear,
well it may have been pretty boring when
you're sitting around waiting for the
black hole to go pop.
But afterwards that's really boring.
So this was picture I thought off and
being rather depressed by it thinking
that stats are that fate.
You see the faith of all the interesting
things happening.
Ultimate fate is this unbelievably
boring final state.
Okay,
this is an emotional argument but it
gives me a bit of leeway.
So I began to think,
well it's not going to be us who are
going to be bored because we're not
going to be around the main things that
will be around.
We'll be photons and it's pretty hard to
borrow a photon for two very good
reasons.
One is it probably doesn't have
conscious experience,
not about sure.
So,
but the other is more of the science
point that they don't measure time cause
the photon has no mass.
It travels at the speed of light and the
way relativity works,
it means that clocks stop if you like.
So if it had experiences it,
the moment of its creation would be one
moment and the next moment would be
infinity.
And so they're just zip up to infinity
without noticing thing.
Now she had been doing work on this kind
of thing,
thinking more about gravitational
radiation and how you measure it's
energy and things like that.
And it was a very useful picture too.
Squashed down infinity.
A useful thing to think about here,
if you seen these pictures by the Dutch
artist Mc Escher,
and there are those which are called
circle limits and there's a very famous
one with angels and devils interlocking
and they get all crowded up until the
edge.
They weren't.
You've got to think about is that this
is a kind of geometry called hyperbolic
geometry and the angels and devils live
in that geometry and the ones right
close to the edge think they're the same
size and same shape as the ones in the
middle.
Oh,
are you good?
Yeah.
Great.
And so the idea is that if you look at
it from the angels and devils point of
view,
that's infinity,
that boundary.
But from our point of view,
we can look at it and we have what's
called a conformal map.
That picture is a conformal map,
but that means is that little shapes are
quite consistently drawn,
but they can be big or small and you
don't care about whether they're big or
they're small.
Small shapes are accurate or angles if
you like her correctly drawn.
So it's what's called a conformal map
and that can form a map,
describes infinity.
Now you can do the same thing to the
universe.
When I say do it,
I mean you can imagine it where this
remote future,
you can squash it down just like in the
essure picture to a finite boundary.
And as far as the things with no mass,
they don't have a way of measuring how
big or small it is.
The maxwell equations don't know the
scale,
they don't care.
It's that work just as well for smaller,
so big,
and you can stretch it in someplace and
squash it somewhere else.
As long as the stretching and squashing
is isotropic.
So just as much one way as the other
way,
which means more or less that you keep
what I go.
The light cones there,
and that's not going to details here,
but it means that that if you have
things without mass and most
particularly the photons,
then that boundary is just like anywhere
else and the photons goes zipping up to
it and so you might think they got to
have somewhere to go,
okay,
well that's a,
you don't have to think that,
but that was the point of view.
I had the photons need the need
somewhere to enter it in a way,
but then where does it go?
But then there's the other picture,
which is the opposite.
Then there's the big bang.
Now you can do a similar sort of trick
there,
which is stretching it out and making it
into a boundary and that can be done
too.
I played around with these ideas for a
long time and the standard cosmology
models you can do it with,
but the more complicated cosmology
models you might have one,
which is very complicated,
Big Bang.
The general ones don't look like that at
all,
so you need to condition which tells you
that the big bang was a very special
kind that it was.
It's all tied up with this thing called
the second law of thermodynamics and
there's all ties together with physics
in a way,
which perhaps we don't have time to talk
about,
but it seemed to me a really good idea
to have the condition on the big bang
that you could continue it in the same
way I should say.
The idea of doing this was a former
student of mine,
Paul Todd,
who's a colleague of mine and he used
this continuum,
conform or continuation is,
is a nice way of saying what the
condition is on the big bang to give you
what you want,
but that's a huge condition,
but it nevertheless,
it's what starts our universe off in in
a
very special state,
which is what we live off.
In a way.
It's the second law of thermodynamics
needs that to get going.
Anyway,
I don't know if you want to worry about
that.
But anyway,
the point was that it looks as though
it's a good condition on the big bang,
but it also should be conformally.
Uh,
like a boundary,
which if you had no mass,
you wouldn't notice it.
Okay.
You've got particles with mass running
around near the Big Bang,
but as you get closer and closer and
closer to the energy goes up,
the temperature goes zooming,
zooming up these,
zipping around at such a speed that the
energy of their emotion is much bigger
than the equals MC squared mass.
Einstein's mass,
the energy in the mass as a certain
amount,
but when they get so hot,
you can forget about the mass.
So they like photons behave like
particles without mass.
And so they're just interested in the
conformal geometry.
So the crazy idea I had,
not just only you stretch out the big
bang,
he squashed on the infinity,
but maybe our big bang was squashed down
infinity of a previous Ian.
So I'm saying our Ian began with a big
bang,
ended up with this exponential
expansion.
There was another one before us.
They will be another one astros.
There was another one before that and so
on.
So it's an infinite cycle of big banks.
That's the picture and constant
expansion to the point where there's no
more energy and then somehow or another
a big bang comes out of that.
Yes,
that's right.
Well that's the tricky part that people
have trouble.
It's universally accepted that the big
bang was an event.
There's no pretty well universally
theories that are attractive.
I would say nothing terribly popular.
There are certain ideas which say you
can continue into the before the Big
Bang Paul Steinhauser,
what are they thinking?
It's,
it's,
it has things in common with my model,
but it's not quite the same.
And,
and you see it still is,
he,
there wasn't right not long after
Einstein produces theory and this
Alexandra Friedman who was a Russian
mathematical physicist and he produced
the first cousin cause mammalogy
mammals.
And one of these was the one which has
sort of bounces and big bang.
It expands,
it contracts again and it bounces and
conduct.
And so that was the one of his models.
The only trouble is if you put
irregularities into these models,
you get black holes and these black
holes component and an incredible mess
at the end.
And that doesn't join onto a nice
smooth,
big bang.
The next one.
So you have trouble with those models,
but still people take these things
seriously.
And as I say stanhart and tour,
I kind of a model which is like that.
So these are the things one has to think
about.
My own view is that they don't take into
account the,
the,
the black hole problem,
which is that,
uh,
my one gets rid of that because the
black holes or evaporate away by hawking
evaporation.
And uh,
so it's forms a model.
I used to give talks about this feeling
quite happy.
Nobody would ever prove it wrong so I
can go on and talking.
Well that's a no,
I wasn't quite happy with that.
I thought maybe you could see signals
coming through.
So I had one idea about that,
but more recently,
and this is only just this year,
um,
I have to polish colleagues,
that's Christoph Meisner and Pav on near
[inaudible].
And there is a Korean who works in New
York or Daniel an and we,
the four of us have a paper,
which I think today or tomorrow will be
the new improved version of this paper
should be on the archive and this,
the title of the paper is,
are we seeing hawking points in the cmb
sky?
Now,
what's a hawking point?
You see,
I talked about the black holes sitting
the previous aeon two hours,
assuming it's more or less like ours,
there will be black holes in clusters of
galaxies.
Huge,
enormous ones swallowing up,
predict pretty well the whole cluster
and what happens to the energy in those
black holes?
Well,
it goes out in hawking radiation and it
takes an age,
ages and ages and ages,
maybe 10 to a hundred year,
Google years or something.
Yeah,
ages and ages,
but all that energy in the picture comes
up basically one point.
Think of that as your picture and right
at the very edge you see that an awful
lot of angels and devils squashed
together there so that the entire
radiation from that single black hole
will be squashed into that little point.
Now where on the other side,
what do we see?
Well there will be a big release of
energy at that point and that's what we
call the hawking point and it spreads
out.
You see what we see in the cosmic
microwave background.
This is radiation coming from all
directions and this radiation doesn't
come from the big bang.
Exactly.
It comes from 380,000
years after the big bang.
So there's a sort of last scattering
surface where the photons which are
trying to get out finally,
finally can escape and we see them now
that spread out from the hawking point
to what you see and the cosmic microwave
background in the last scattering
surface is something of the diameter of
about eight times the diameter of the
moon.
No bigger,
no smaller.
No,
you wouldn't see the whole thing because
our past cone,
where were we?
What we see is to cut across it.
We don't see the whole thing,
but we see probably most of it.
So you could imagine something from
about four to eight times the moon's
diameter,
which is a small region,
which is highly energetic,
more energetic in the middle.
And it tapers off as you go to the edge.
And we seem to see these things,
the analysis that,
um,
that the polls,
they have the techniques and the actual
analyzing the data.
This is the planck satellite data was
done by Daniel Lan.
And then we look at the data and we seem
to see an effect which see what you do
is you,
we've got only one universe.
That's what they're complaining about.
So how do you know if something's real
or not?
Whether you make zillions of fake
universes and you compare this with
them.
There's a lot of technique about how you
do this.
But,
um,
Daniel first did a thousand of these
fakes and they were sort of two sizes of
these.
You look at these rings to see whether
the temperature goes out from the
outside to the middle.
And there were two sizes,
both within the size of the essay,
about four degrees across the sky.
And um,
there was no evidence of them at all in
the simulation.
So this is a real effect.
Okay.
Then people were skeptical of this for
one reason or another.
So Daniel did another,
well,
10,000
altogether,
and you occasionally the one or two
which do what,
two or three,
to be precise,
where you see this effect in the
simulations.
But if you work out the probability that
this is a real effect,
you come up with a confidence level of
99.98%
that this is a real effect.
So we're waiting to see what people say
about this.
What are your thoughts on multiverses?
Well,
you see,
this is different because this is the
what?
Sequential.
Yeah.
So I don't call it a multiverse.
They each influence the next one.
And so they're not independent worlds.
Right.
But in the,
the,
the possibility of Independent.
Yeah.
Well,
you see,
there are two reasons for believing
multiverses.
One of them is the quantum reason that
maybe we have the shorting this dead and
the livecast they in different worlds
and they separate universes.
I don't believe that argument.
I don't think that's the right way to
look at quantum mechanics,
but many people do.
And that suggests that you might have
these multiple universities and some
sense on attractive about that to you.
It doesn't explain what we see.
So he wanted a theory which explains the
world we see and the world we see.
You get collapse the state does.
And to explain that,
well it's only because we've drifted off
into some world and another version of
ourselves as drift into another one and
some c one and the other side of the
other and they're all in super position.
It doesn't explain why you see one world
and she has this kind of coherence.
I mean lots of people try and there are
many attempts at the sort of thing.
It's,
it's quite a widely held view and if you
believe quantum mechanics,
the collapse is not real and it doesn't
happen.
And all the alternatives,
the dead cats on the cab coexists in
different worlds.
That's the interpretation.
That's a view.
I don't think that I want,
I want an explanation for the world we
live in.
And you don't see cast different worlds
with cats and well it's a long story,
right?
I mean it's clearly,
it's a view you can hold to and if you
don't want to monkey with quantum
mechanics,
it's where you lead.
So that's,
that's right.
That's the alternative.
I,
they don't make a single try to change
quantum mechanics at all.
And then you are led to this multi
world,
many,
many world picture.
I think it even doesn't make that much
sense.
So you've got to be careful about it.
That whether they are really like
different,
distinct worlds,
I don't think it really,
my view is it doesn't really work,
but let me not try and attack that.
And I think I have a different view,
which is that the theory is not quite
quite right.
Right.
And that,
um,
there is something which makes the
collapse into a physical process.
And,
uh,
the,
there's only one world now the other
many worlds view,
which is comes from a different reason.
And that is that that seem there seem to
be various accidents,
um,
in,
well maybe one of them being that the
neutron is just slightly more massive
than the Proton.
That's one.
There are lots of other accidents.
We see that if they were a little
different than life as we know,
it couldn't happen.
And so how do you explain this?
Well,
some people say,
well,
all these universes with different
values of these constants all coexist.
It's just we only see the one that we're
in because the numbers come out right
for us.
So that's what's called an anthropic
argument.
Okay.
I can see the argument.
I don't like it much.
It's sort of,
I think we need a better explanation for
why the numbers are what we see and so
on.
But that's that that one makes more
sense to me than the other one.
So I saw,
I think maybe it has to take that
seriously,
but it's certainly not the view I'm
presenting here with this picture.
It's for someone like me.
It's so interesting to know that there's
still a considerable amount of
speculation.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
Well it's,
it's,
there's a lot of speculation,
but a lot of it is pretty off the wall.
And then a lot of people think mine are
off the wall and see who's to say,
okay,
I'm,
I'm no man,
no.
And so,
okay.
And I did think in decent things in the
past,
but you just didn't trust this abuse is
nice.
So I guess that's what people think.
I don't know.
But you see,
if it was just me,
I could understand that.
But I've got these posts and I went an
Armenian colleague who's done things on
this two and a,
it can't be that we all all off the
rails I think.
No,
there's something out there.
And now with their talking points,
there's something people can really go
out and look for and if they don't see
you and something funny going on
somewhere,
if they do see them,
there's something else going funny on
which,
which they'll have to think of another
explanation unless it's my explanation.
They'll have to think of a different
view from the current inflation view,
which is in real trouble with these
observations as far as I can see.
Do you anticipate in any foreseeable
time in the future,
uh,
a better understanding of dark matter
and dark energy or perhaps a better
definition of what those things are?
Um,
yeah,
we see,
I think my,
my own current view is that dark energy
as it's called,
is the cosmological constant.
Now that's a lot of explanation if you'd
like,
because why is it,
why is it that the value it has,
why is it they're tall and they're
certainly questions about that,
which I agree with.
Dot.
Matta.
I didn't go into this,
but in the scheme of mine,
it has to be there.
When I say it,
I mean that if you want the equations to
make sense,
which crossover from our remote future
to the big bang of the next Ian,
you have to have a creation of a
dominant new material,
which is scaler.
And as I said,
it doesn't spin.
It's just ordinary particles and that
they only interact gravitationally.
And that's what we see.
But the theory that I'm putting forward
would make these things very massive
there about what's called the planck
mass.
I don't know exactly cause there's some
freedom in this.
Something like the prank planck mass,
which people describe as the massive of
fleas.
I don't quite know why they make it,
but that's about 10 to the minus five
grams.
So you're looking at the 100000th of a
gram.
So it's sort of an appreciable size.
It's not,
it's not like basic particles in physics
measurable.
It's the sort of measurable thing you
could imagine you could get that get
hold of in some way,
but that's huge for for a fundamental
particle.
So it's a,
it's a wild idea from that point of
view.
But also they should decay and they
should decay into gravitational signals,
which may be,
could be seen by Lego,
maybe have been seen by lego and thrown
in the rubbish bin because they'd be
different types of signals from what
people would expect.
I wouldn't like to put my money anywhere
there,
but I'm lacking hoping that these dark
matter particles are the ones that come
from the theory that,
that I'm putting forward.
So that will be another consequence of
this particular point of view.
And they've observed,
correct me if I'm wrong,
entire galaxies that they believe are
the consist of dark matter.
There is Liz,
let me see if I remember what it is.
There's some galaxies the other way
around,
which don't seem to have any dark
matter.
There are other galaxies which have huge
amounts.
That's probably what you're referring
to,
whether they were only dot.
Imagine
you'd have trouble seeing them.
Right because dot.
Mazur off til he,
it was just a measured thing.
It may be,
I don't know that one.
It's quite possible.
Yeah,
I don't see why not.
Um,
they just have to have some reason why
they clump together in this way.
You see it's quite possible if galaxies
collide,
then when you see the stars tend to go
through,
so they would accompany with they'd
company the dark matter,
the dust and the galaxies tends to get
stuck and stay where it is.
So if two collide,
then you'd have a big pile of dust in
the middle.
But I think the dark matter tends to
carry on through with the stars.
I don't know.
There may be some process which could
produce just islands of dark matter.
I don't know.
When you discussed the cosmos,
maybe the single most intriguing
possibility to us as human beings is
what other intelligent life,
if any,
is out there.
And how interesting is that to you
because you spent so much time studying
the fundamental particles of the
universe itself.
How interested are you in the
possibility of other intelligent life
forms or have you just like put that out
into the,
it's just so ridiculously unlikely or so
far away from us that we're probably
never going to make contact.
Where do you see it's not?
So there's this Seti program looking at
to see where they can see signals from
listening to civilizations.
The problem there from my perspective is
that although they might be out there,
they've got to have had a real headstart
on us before he would see them.
They might have done so.
But then I dunno,
you see actually via,
he goes to John,
who's my Armenian colleague and who
looked also for these ring shaped things
and looked at them in a different way
from the Polish people.
But um,
we seem to have seen something there.
But we wrote a paper in which we
speculated on beings from the previous
Ian communicating with us.
And the advantage there is that you're
looking at the really advanced
civilizations,
really the,
you see
billions of years ago that they,
their universe disappeared and then had
to come back to a big bank statements
and those could come through and somehow
or another,
those signals Romaine.
It's conceivable.
I agree.
It's pretty far fetched,
but you know,
who knows what.
So Ian's,
how many billions of years are you
talking about?
Like the,
the big bang.
14 billion.
Yes.
But you see that's way,
way at the beginning in a sense or at
three quarters of the way through.
In another sense it depends on how you
draw the picture in the sense of
interestingness or
formal picture.
We are already three quarters of the way
through.
So 14 billion now.
So we have
how much content does he is you see the
trouble is it's this a cheat to cheat
the year count.
It's as much as you like.
It depends on the on on something else.
The mass has to feed out and how you
measure the time it becomes problematic
and it's either infinity you see,
which isn't much use or you might have
different definitions of time,
which depends on what particle you're
using as your clocks and things like
that.
So are you essentially saying that it's
entirely possible that we are the
furthest in terms of our technological
achievement and our understanding of the
universe itself?
It's possible that we're at the front of
the line though there might be some
other intelligent life forms in the
universe,
but they might be behind us.
Well there would have been,
I mean,
I'm not saying they got through,
you say,
well maybe they have techniques for
getting through,
but that's,
that's a bit hard to imagine.
But,
um,
maybe information from them,
mcgee it through and maybe you mean from
the previous els?
Yes.
They might have got through like somehow
or another survived.
Yes.
But it would have to be in the form of
photons or something.
The,
I know you could,
it's not,
I'm talking about ridiculous
speculators.
Sure.
In coding information.
The photons.
Yes.
Wow.
It's conceivable.
I don't want to say that I see it
happening or anything,
but it's not out of the question that
they could develop some technology which
would get information,
which might be them in some sense,
uh,
across,
in the form of photons.
But you're not optimistic about current
intelligent life somewhere in the
universe.
Not too optimistic.
Just because,
um,
well maybe it took us a long time to get
going because the dinosaurs were there
for a while and somebody might've got in
there earlier and they're different
planets and they could've got there
quite ahead of us.
It's,
it's conceivable.
I'm not going to rule it out.
I just not terribly optimistic about it.
No,
I think it's worth doing.
It's worth looking.
Yes,
but it's not something that you're
really not servicing.
I'm expecting.
It's not so much.
I be curious.
Certainly then I'm not expecting it.
I guess is it just because of the
overall lack of real evidence and it's
just not an attractive thing for you to
pursue?
It's quite attractive.
It's short.
You know?
I've just been doing other things and I
don't know there's enough to do in the
world.
I haven't really come to terms that very
hugely.
So I know there's this activity and I,
I'd be interested to see if any kind of,
you know,
if this,
there was this thing that came past that
some people speculated was sent there by
and different intelligence,
which came quite close in our solar
system.
Oh,
that was that strange looking.
This trailer shaved.
Yes,
that's right.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't see any real reason to believe
it's alien supposedly because of the way
it was traveling though was the idea or
something.
I really serious about it.
See what these people did suggest.
It might be something sent by an alien
civilization.
So it's worth you if one could make
connect with it in some way.
But I don't know,
I guess it's too far away now.
He wants another thing that's so
uniquely fascinating for us.
The concept of sale of another of
another life form out there.
Oh sure.
Yes.
Yeah.
No you see there are lots of things I'm
interested in the ones I talked to you
about and perhaps some of the main
months.
Although the consciousness one is I'm
glad that there are people doing it and
you see this is one of the things,
there's this institute that's that's
being created using my name and uh,
James Tag is involved with this,
started it and I was quite,
I'm not admitting them,
worried about having my name attached to
this thing when I didn't know much about
it.
But it seems to me a really important
thing where you can deliberate purpose
of it is to develop ideas which are make
sense but are not mainstream.
And one of these was the consciousness
thing.
So,
you know,
Stuart Hameroff is doing it,
but it's not a activity that's being
taken pot people researching it in,
in detail in other parts of the world.
So to have a place which supports that
kind of thing is great and I think
that's very good.
But when I heard about it at first,
I thought,
well,
most of my interests are on the physics
side and not so much in biology,
which I'm pretty ignorant about.
And there are lots of ideas on that
side,
not just the cosmology,
but ideas and building experiments which
might detect the collapse of the wave
function.
And one idea to look at Bose-einstein
condensates said,
I have a colleague that's Yvette
[inaudible] who I knew about and who had
these ideas of how to use,
um,
Bose-einstein condensates to detect
gravitational waves.
And that's also very,
you know,
not a mainstream way of looking at it,
but a very clever idea.
And the Bose-einstein condensates
because that's so quantum mechanical and
they're so cold,
they're almost virtually absolute zero.
And they can keep external disturbances
from causing problems and you can
manipulate them in ways to make them in
two places at once.
People have done this kind of thing.
And so it might well be a good way of
testing the one,
the Schrodinger cat thing.
And we went,
uh,
whether the state reduction or the
collapse of way function is a phenomenon
in which is kind,
which I hope might be like gravitational
effect.
And in,
in that case,
if it is,
then that will be relevant to the
consciousness problem.
So all these things tied in various
ways.
And so the hope was that these things,
which are,
um,
you know,
could be supported.
And I thought it was important because
there's always the danger of such an
institute being regarded as flaky,
but he's doing weird things.
Who Cares?
So the important point from my
perspective is that they should be
things which can me and either now
immediately tested experimentally or
when a few years.
So that things which are really,
you can get your hotel,
you can get and test them and see
whether they're right or not.
So this would be a protection against
thinking of,
well these,
these crazy ideas that are being
pursued,
they have to be ideas which are capable
of tests and have a reasonable chance
of,
of showing evidence in favor in their
favor or against,
you know,
whichever would be interesting and
important to know.
So from the outside looking in,
to me it's so fascinating to watch
intellectuals as a,
like yourself that are bouncing these
ideas around that are possible but are
not mainstream.
And it seems to me that it's a
precarious sort of tight rope walk.
Like you don't want to say anything
ridiculous that's not true.
So he would love to say something that
seems to be ridiculous but turns out to
be in fact accurate and provable.
And so that was this dance.
I absolutely agree.
Yes,
that's absolutely right.
And of course you've got to play with
ideas which are on the sort of edge of
what we know otherwise you're stuck with
what we know.
And these things will simply get
channeled down the old roots and,
and you,
you need to be able to break,
break free of those from time to time,
but not in a,
in a way which is too crazy to be
examined.
See whether there's truth in these ideas
are not because of the synchronization
that people have to go towards Wu or
towards crazy ideas.
It is important for the skepticism.
Right.
And it is important for the scrutiny.
Yes.
Oh absolutely.
So there's real,
it was real danger in that ledge.
I agree.
Well you see this is a strange kind of
problem you see because with these
observations,
I'm not about,
they're hawking points which I was
describing,
but the earlier ones about black hole
collisions and my Armenian colleague and
I had written a couple of papers on this
and we hadn't gotten any response at
all.
And the Polish people and they'd written
papers,
two of them accepted by respectable
journals.
And I'm Chris,
I've asked me,
you know,
what kind of responses you got and I say
zero.
And so I see him.
What about you?
How about what people respond to zero.
So this is kind of spooky.
You see,
we've got these things out there in the
literature,
refereed a accepted publications and
instead of people saying this is a load
of nonsense,
look,
it doesn't make any sense for this
reason and this disagrees with this
observation and so,
and that was fine.
If I see that,
I might be unhappy with it,
but you've got something to work on and
you say,
oh,
I see what's wrong.
Something needs modifying here.
Ah,
that doesn't explain properly.
That's what's needed or yes,
no,
you're,
you're right.
I had been abandoned this idea.
All of these things come from criticisms
and to have absolutely no tension
whatsoever paid to these papers.
Something I find spooky.
Why do you think there's no attention
paid?
I don't know.
I don't really know.
I mean one of the things is there's so
much information and that people don't
have time.
They've grown their own projects and
they didn't want to pay attention and
they think it looks crazy because it's
too much outside the picture of the
world that they have.
And I think a lot of it's that and they
maybe say,
well look,
I've been thinking,
you know,
I'm an old guy now and I maybe I did
good things in the past,
but um,
maybe I've gone a bit off the rails,
but I think that,
you know,
I've got colleagues,
it's not just me and these respect to
people who work on these things too.
So I don't think that can be a complete
explanation.
Maybe it's part of it.
Well,
the sheer volume of papers that are
published,
it's got to be impossible to keep up
with all that.
I think that's a big part of the trouble
because there are other ideas which,
which to me look crazy and do other
people don't look in ears.
And as crazy as my idea as you see.
So maybe that's why there's a lot of
them have more attention page than the
ones we,
I actually,
I'm curious to know whether the hawking
points we'll take off or not.
Well,
I'm so happy there's people like you
doing this kind of work.
And then someone condensing it down to
an understandable point that someone
like me can absorb and just tried to get
a better picture of this insane reality
that we're living in.
But it is pretty weird subsidies.
And it seems like the more I talked to
people like yourself and the more you
study this,
it doesn't get less weird.
It gets more weird.
Yes.
I think that's right.
Well,
I don't know more information.
It seems to be more fantastic.
There's suddenly a lot of very weird
things,
but the point about them is that they
got to make sense,
mathematical sense.
They've got agree with observation facts
and that rules out.
A lot of the really weird ones
does.
But even the ones that are observable
and do adhere to the facts,
they're so fantastic.
It's so the,
the reality,
this is one of the things that's most
frustrating about people's inclination
to lean towards the Wu and I,
I've been guilty of it myself and so
attractive.
But what's frustrating about it is that
provable reality is so titanic Lee,
bizarre.
That's true.
No,
I agree that it's almost like why bother
with the woo reality is you can make a
good point in and of itself.
You're absolutely right.
No,
it's very,
very strange.
Strange
in quantum mechanics in so many ways is,
but you see you got to,
I think there's a little bit of a danger
of separating the things which are,
well first of all,
it can be just wrong.
Secondly,
there are things which do require
quantum mechanics to be changed in some
way and there'd be other ones which are
within quantum mechanics are just weird
and that's absolutely true.
There are these things which,
which I believe have to be true as much
as the Dib died in the womb.
Quantum mechanics,
people who follow the party lines and so
on.
Yeah,
I mean these quantum entanglements,
the fact that things can be whatever it
is,
a couple of thousand kilometers
separated and yet know each other and a
way.
You can't explain that there are
separate individuals.
They behave as though they're one called
the and tangled state.
And you can make experiments which
revealed that,
I mean,
it's was a John Bell who is an Irish
theoretical physicists who really made
it,
made all this very clear.
These things are real manifestations of
the peculiarity of quantum mechanics and
really out there in the world.
Was it jbs Haldane it said,
the world is not only queer than you
suppose it's queer.
Then you can suppose,
all right,
that's what this is,
right?
Indeed,
yes.
This is that kind of thing.
Well,
listen sir,
thank you for your time.
I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate talking to you and
thank you for all your work and your,
your contribution to our understanding
of what we're looking at here.
What I hope it helps a bit,
but it helps a lot.
I appreciate you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you,
sir.
Hm.